last time on Nightwing training so over
the last two installments of this
Nightwing training series I've discussed
a leg workout for explosive leg strength
to help you jump higher and kick harder
as well as a push and pull day to help
you climb over walls punch bad guys and
perform calisthenics movements but
there's more to do in this part three
we're going to be looking at a core
workout to help you twist and torque
your body through the air as well as to
provide extra stability and balance even
when you're at a disadvantage and in a
month or two in part four we'll be
looking at mobility to help you move
through a greater range of motion with
strength and in that video I'll also be
returning back to the gymnastics Hall to
see if all this training has helped my
own gymnastics and calisthenics at all
so the core is a really misunderstood
concept most people will fall into one
of two categories either they pretty
much ignore their core training because
I think well my core is involved in
every movement so why do I need to train
it I only deadlift all they do loads in
those sit-ups in order to get a six-pack
without thinking about all the other
things that involved in core training
gym last a little bit different they
understand that the core is actually
made up of lots of different muscles all
working in tandem in order to optimize a
performance your stability and your
olicity twist through the air because if
we were doing is sit-ups then you're
only moving through one plane of motion
and actually your core is designed to
help you move through multiple planes of
motion it's for twisting for bending to
the side for bending fours for bending
backwards and by developing more
strength you're going to do all those
things more effectively it'll help to
punch harder to perform more gymnastics
tricks and moves to perform every single
exercise in the gym with greatest
strength and you'll even look better so
let's break it down if we're going to
Train like Dick Grayson and really hit
our core in a functional and effective
manner what do we need to think about
well we need to think about the
different muscles that comprise the core
and there's more than I'm gonna talk
about here but the ones I want to focus
on for this workout the ones that you
really need to be hitting are the rectus
abdominis that's the sheet of muscle on
the front that gives you your six-pack
the transverse abdominis the deeper
layer underneath the six-pack which acts
like your nature's weight belt it holds
your whole lower midsection in place
stabilizes yourself through movements
and prevents injury then you've got your
internal and external obliques which
have a twisting bending to the side
moving in that kind of way and then you
have the erector spinae and in
particular the longest tzimmes for Rakus
and these are the muscles that keep your
back up straight and allow you to bend
backwards and they work as antagonist to
the rectus abdominis that pulls
phors they pull you backwards you end up
with this nice amount of tension that
keeps you straight up in the middle so
they're working all throughout the day
so if you want to train the rectus
abdominus then we need to be training
that bending forwards and motion bending
at the waist not at their hips so we use
this in crunches and leg raises and it's
really important when it comes to doing
a backflip when I spend the whole day
trying to do a back flip one of the
things I was really surprised about was
how much my abs hurt at the end of it
this makes a lot of sense when you
consider the fact that you're jumping in
the air and then tucking into a ball
bringing your knees up to your chest
this is the most important part of a
backflip as a supportive muscle need to
be active all the time and that means
it's very high in slow twitch muscle
fiber so if you're just doing situps not
only only working the rectus abdominis
but you're also not providing enough
resistance or enough explosiveness it's
what he do much at the same time a lot
of people when they do sit-ups they
won't crunch they'll just bend their hip
so the whole body folds forwards that's
using the hip flexors it's not using
your stomach or your abs at all at the
same time a lot of people will only
train a partial range of motion with
their sit-up because your rectus
abdominis capable of pulling you
forwards all the way from a backwards
bent over position so if you're just
doing situps where your back is only
ever flat then you're not training it
through that full range of motion and
especially if you're not going all the
way up same thing goes again for leg
raises
so some exercise I'm going to
incorporate into our Dick Grayson
Nightwing training our hanging leg
raises done correctly and then you're
gonna drop set those straight down to
frog kicks and bringing your knees up
really adding the challenge and to
increase the resistance you can try
lifting a medicine ball or a weight
plate in between your knees when you're
doing those frog kicks or even between
your feet whilst you're doing leg raises
and you'll really feel this one the
Martha crunch is an exercise where you
bend over backwards over say a BOSU ball
or anything else like that and exercise
ball and then you just sit up all the
way from that position so you're going
through a greater range of motion Pike
pulses can also help me to train a
different range of motion for your abs
and when it comes to resistance I'm a
really big fan of the cable crunch so
now to the transverse abdominis Oh
nature's weight belt this braces you and
you move it's what keeps your abs nice
and flat and if you find that you've got
a six-pack but you have a gut hanging
out there probably is because you
haven't trained your transverse
abdominal this will keep everything
sucked in nicely so you don't only have
a detailed six-pack but also a flat one
so if you train your transverse
abdominal you can use add vacuums that
means bringing your belly button in
towards your spine and then hold in that
position and you can use anything where
your body is in that rigid
so you can practice with front leavers
you can practice with the planche you
can just use plank which is one of the
most popular ways to train the
transverse abdominal you can also just
do lots of press ups of course that will
also work as long as you're really
conscious of keeping that body nice and
straight
even pull-ups if you're doing the same
thing one of the best things you can do
though is a hollow body hold this is a
move from gymnastics what you're
basically doing is contracting the
transverse abdominis and really creating
a really solid core a solid trunk and
then just balancing on it to do this
you'll sit down and lie flat on your
back then you'll bring that belly button
in towards the spine again to really
contract the transverse abdominal tuck
your chin in bring your arms forwards
and then you're gonna hold yourself in
that position with your legs also
elevated whilst you keep the small of
your back touching the ground and as
long as the small of your back is
touching the ground and your stomach is
sucked in then you're doing this
correctly and then you can progress to
pointing your toes out forwards and your
arms out behind you and this will help
to build a really solid strong trunk
which is really essential when you're
doing something like the planche now on
to the erector spinae director of spin I
however you want to say it and like I
said these are for straightening up your
back and even leaning over backwards so
this becomes extremely important if you
wanna do something like a back
handspring we need to be able to whip
your arms behind you really fast it's
also really important again for keeping
your body nice and rigid through a range
of other different movements the most
obvious way that you can train your
erector spinae which most people already
know about is through Superman so that's
lying on the ground then lifting your
arms up and your legs up up in the air
of course you can you to the Roman chair
or if you listen to Christopher summers
from gymnastic bodies he's a massive
advocate of the jefferson curl where you
gradually lower your spine moving
through each vertebrae holding a weight
in your hands be careful with this
really build up to it slowly but he
believes this can help you to prevent
all sorts of different injuries the most
important thing to consider is that if
you're going to be upping the amount of
training you're doing for your rectus
abdominus making it stronger then you
also do the same thing for your rectus
pnai otherwise gonna create an imbalance
that can lead to ketosis and all kinds
of other postural and health issues but
if you're like me you can just practice
putting a baby in and out of her crib
which is so ridiculously low down it's
like it's designed to break your spine
and finally we have the obliques which
are so overlooked in training for a
number of reasons actually one of those
being a lot of people don't want to
build up bigger Bleek's because they
think they're just gonna make them look
thick down the bottom and ruin their
upside down triangle aesthetic it
doesn't have to if
focus more on twisting movements but
also who cares this channels about
performance so that's what we were
interested in and if you want to be
Nightwing you have to build your
obliques because therefore twisting your
body and for bending your body and if
you're gonna be doing a B twist an
aerial a side flip anything like this
you're gonna need to better quickly
twist your body in the air likewise any
martial artists need to be able to
quickly generate power in their hips
when the throwing a punch whether
they're throwing the kick a roundhouse
kick your torso generates a lot of power
if you want to be able to twist that way
then you should think about that too so
how we're going to train our oblique
well by doing twisting movements so that
means things like the cable resistance
punch out the oblique twist with the
cable side plank twists hanging leg
twists bicycle crunches the pile off
press in the bare crunch and another
thing you want to incorporate into our
maitland training is offset exercises
exercises where you are moving more
weight on one side than on the other so
like a suitcase carry which is a type of
loaded carry or like a one-armed barbell
press or something like this even
one-armed push-ups here you're facing
more resistance on one side of your body
so your breaks of working to brace and
prevent yourself from bending in that
direction this will not only help to
make us even stronger and able to move
even more gracefully but at the same
time it makes you impossible to push
over which is awesome stay tuned for an
upcoming video on contralateral training
it's highly relevant to this and it's
really interesting so look that's it
that's our night wing core training and
if you incorporate these all into a
workout and I will share a link in the
description down below where you can
find a sample ABS day core day then
you'll be able to develop more agility
greater balanced more power in your
kicks and your twists is crucial if you
want to be able to flips it's crucial if
you want to balance long beams it's
crucial if you want to Train like
Nightwing like I say stay tuned for the
final part where I'll be talking about
mobility and also putting all this to
the test by heading back to the gym and
seeing if I can flip it better so thanks
ton for watching guys hope found this
video useful and interesting if you did
then please leave a like down below
that'll help me out immensely comment
and let me know how you train your core
and if there's anything I missed maybe
which superhero you'd like to see me
tackle next time I'm thinking spider-man
to tie in with the new film I've got
lots more other cool stuff on the way
like I said that contralateral exercise
video coming up there'll be looking at
samurai training go the productivity
stuff gonna be sharing some of my
favorite books so if that sounds good to
them thanks a ton for watching and I'll
see you next time bye for now
you